I just went on suppose that I have I had
an absolute ball every time I go to one
of these events you get a chance to meet
the fans you get a chance to talk to the
show talk about the show with the fans
it's just fantastic but I'm a father
heal myself and but to meet such a
passionate wonderful interested an
interesting group it's a real pleasure
for me I think sometimes you know when
you're kind of doing what you do and you
think is that okay then you come here
and you get feedback from people who
absolutely live breathe and eat Westeros
and you think yeah they don't care I
just love these events I'm today has
been an absolute ball count ready out is
that I think beauty here is sort I call
them baby because we're both the in and
it gets confusing otherwise so I think
Benny here is covered pretty well every
base there and the thing you're very
much aware of is that they know far more
about the show than you do yeah one of
the things about these yet put to test
don't you test it every time I get
nervous when fans approach almost what
do they know what do they know they know
so much and what they don't know they
sort of like you know they're constantly
in touch with each other and they've got
all sorts of theories about it well half
the time we we don't know in the same
way and plus you know no you get the
scripts and we only get the scripts that
we're in used to be we were able to see
everything but the guts are like you
know nervous about letting stuff I you
only see the scripts that you're in so
you don't necessary for your theories
you sort of think well what do I know
you know it's much more effective it
means that when you say I don't know you
really don't know so it works quite well
and it's a situation where it's okay to
say I don't know you know but a lot of
fun when it comes to well from the very
beginning you know I figured that man
was gonna bite the dust somewhere I'm
David and Dan
they're pretty classy guys they phoned
me to tell me Marin morghulis that's
you're a large chump but they said that
you'd see a really nasty side to the
character and I'd have a great death I
thought I was gonna get to kill somebody
popular I thought you know I was gonna
get to kill brown or something and I got
the script and everything oh my god oh
it was awful you have three kids at home
if somebody touched one of my children
let me tell you something it would take
that person a lot longer to die than
Mara
really so yep they were extraordinarily
upsetting scenes to do and the biggest
challenge of my acting career Barnum in
a way I was so grateful to the boys for
giving me this you know giving me this
opportunity because it's what an actor
lives for to get things like this the
actual end at when Maisie and I were
filament
Maisie is just an incredible young
actress absolutely incredible one of the
most stunning young actresses I've ever
seen she's absolutely wonderful
we decided her and I very very early
that in this particular scene we had to
go for it and we went for it no point I
had complete trust in her she had
complete trust in me it was technically
very difficult as well because the eyes
we we filmed that last scene on my last
day unusually enough and it was all
filmed in order so the last take was the
last take from me but very early on in
the day my eyes went don't so I have had
to have prosthetics and for the last
seven or eight hours on set I was
completely blind which was really weird
blood shoots coming up blood gore
diamond oh it was just technically you
know it's very difficult being blind
actually really helped me schewe
vulnerability to that character at that
moment in time so it actually helped but
it was very very difficult and I just
like whatever gods are up there that I
had Maisie to do it with because she is
still wonderful I mean you said you
haven't killed anyone popular I mean
without saying I'm sorry
calling serial popular I'm sorry may be
popular with the fans but I think Marin
was completely forget I said no I mean
yeah I'm pretty certain I'm pretty
certain cereal went at that point I
would be astonished if we saw Sarah
cereal again before the final curtain
I don't think Marin would have left
cereal alive if some fans believe that
cereal became Erin well surely that
would have been revealed
whenever Marin died surely then he would
have appeared which would have actually
been really weird seriously and she's
just killed cereal but no cereal I
believe Marin killed him Marin did not
disobey Cersei ever it was the only
redeeming feature I ever found in the
character his fierce loyal they deserve
a Lannister the only one what am i okay
is the season five I guess you know it
has to be the fight but you know boys
adrenaline you know he kind of just lost
or you know what it may be you know you
just get off on it so although it was
challenging it was actually kind of
exciting you know but that that scene
was not that difficult in that all of
the harpies every single one of them
were stuntmen so they all know what
they're supposed to be doing and I
worked through it first of all with the
stunt coordinator and then I work with
the guys so I mean I know that everybody
arrived me is there to kind of like you
know do what we're meant to do and with
a bit of luck and I know my routines and
I follow their lead I should be safe and
they should be safe which is probably
more to the point I thought you did very
well
I thought your age
the sword came out grace well I do have
to say I was traveling the fact that I
did the whole thing myself but sometimes
people ask you know did you have a
stuntman stand-in and I didn't and I
wouldn't have wanted it and nor would
they wanted it if at all possible you
know but I mean one of the big issues
obviously the fights especially with
actors is because your adrenaline does
get going is that you lose the plot you
know and before you know it you've hit
somebody and you hit them harder than
you meant to and it's like oh you know
but you know fortunately nobody died so
we were fine I mean I would say that for
me that the the real scene that gave me
a lot - a lot to really think about both
before and after was actually the first
scene of my characters return in season
five when Lancel came back it was a
really weird season in a lot of ways for
my character it was a really sort of an
extraordinary experience and sort of
story to tell because I think when he
returned this figure that stands before
Cersei is so kind of so clearly unlike
anything we've ever seen but what was
amazing for me - about the character
Tori was that the rate at which Lancel
Lannister appears in the first episode
and goes from being someone who you
could easily can compute it being a kind
of namaste Shanta sort of member of a
really fairly pacifistic sort of them
monastery to really actually being
someone in the second scene becoming
someone who is incredibly militant and
is actually hiding underneath this as in
admins that was in the first scene this
kind of lucid totally disconnected sort
of almost come out of like a real trauma
lip quivering from the fact that he's
actually really trying at the start to
almost convinced himself that he's under
control and he is not under control
he's trying desperately to remain under
control and then the way that he finds
that control is through violence and
through this faith and through
commitment and I don't want to be too
too intense about it but given current
affairs the fact that we were filming
this this this series whilst current
foreign affairs are going on was even
more harrowing because it was I couldn't
start going gosh if there's no there's
the timing of this is so terrifyingly
inappropriate and appropriate so the
first scene for me was a was it was a
big deal I felt because I got I got
there that day did my my best to kind of
bring that across and for the rest of
the season I had to move very quickly
and in some ways not sequentially to go
from disconnected to actually really
quite violent to really damaged and
broken and and horrible and I know I
know exactly what what ear means about
when it comes to the ED to the
adrenaline rush of getting in a fight
because when I had to arrest the High
Septon and my second scene bursting into
that broth or would Paul Paul Paul Paul
Bentley Utley I had my my nails were
about as long as this microphone because
I've been growing them for the show
because he's so feral I went and I
picked him up and I didn't realize
because I hadn't I was in such in the
zone that I had Wolverine his ribs as I
was reaching underneath him and he
didn't even notice either and suddenly
we just went I cut him up basically by
accident so yes I did make the mistake
of going a bit to accidentally too far
with that but he was naked
it was naked of the day was born and I
felt very very very apologetic for that
so no way to work for you I know right
yeah exactly yeah
it wasn't me in an action film see what
happened anyway it was a lot of fun for
me I mean quite clear everyone's episode
10 it was the most horrific two days I
have three children at home the fact
that the casting in Game of Thrones is
so perfect they couldn't define three
more beautiful angels to beat than the
three they found and the young actresses
that were involved hottie Isabella and
Bella were absolutely fantastic
instinctively they were wonderful young
actresses they made that scene because
if they hadn't reacted the way they did
it wouldn't have worked they were
fantastic what made it worse was that
you know you can't stand character so as
soon as you yelled cut I had to come out
and be in again
couldn't send character but it was the
most upset I think I've ever been ever
in front of the camera because there
were times I'd said look I'm just going
to the bathroom about it burst into
tears now I will promise you when I say
that stick did not touch his children
once and I promise you and I say those
kids had a great day their parents were
there the Game of Thrones said is a very
protected I'm very protective set you
know everybody has really carefully
looked after but it was horrible to act
the role of a man who took pleasure in
doing that it was the most upsetting
scene I've ever done and obviously I'm
really genuinely very proud of everybody
involved in that scene that we pulled it
off everybody who was in that same we
pulled it off and I was really pleased
about that
pressing said enn I mean so Barristan is
still alive in the next book now when
you saw the script for season 5 how did
you feel when you saw that you know you
met fans truthfully miffed in fact I
knew before I even saw the script
because I got the schedule and I in a
way unfortunately I'd read the books so
I had expectations for season 5 and as
soon as I got the schedule I thought
there's something up here because I
thought I'd be doing more weeks and in
fact I was doing less than normal so
immediately I mean I thought well they
must be writing me out and I asked the
line producer for confirmation and he
said basically above my paygrade
you know so I then said we'll get the
boys to give me a ring well I got the
script first and then it was evidenced
in the script and then eventually the
boys gave me a ring if I'm honest I was
a bit distant made any difference but I
felt as a matter of just courtesy I
should have known beforehand you know
and I was disappointed because I was
enjoying playing the part I was looking
forward to actually getting more meat in
the part and I had dared to presume that
I'd at least go into season six and who
knows further
but you know there was a big mistake
right there never presume in Game of
Thrones
yes I obviously shouldn't have dared to
presume and as my colleague here on the
right room has already agreed but you
know so be it the deed is done and I'm
on to other things and that's that but I
do miss it I would have you know you
might come back as a white Walker which
is more than I can do because I'm the
wise left oh no I'm a white Walker if I
came back as a white Walker my part my
character probably have more soul if he
did again as Ian Beatty I think his name
is has said I have no particular
expectations I think it's very important
not to have expectations I do I do i do
feel instinctively that the faith
militant still definitely has a bone to
pick it's an 8 by its very nature it
wants to kind of purge what is basically
an purgable so and I think that in that
sense says it definitely falls into the
crossers pretty significantly ah I don't
know much about the retribution side of
it but I do think that that's certainly
the the battle that has really begun the
war really that has really begun between
the the crown and the faith is is is
well it's pretty is what probably one of
the most major political events is going
on in King's Landing at the moment and
that is to say that there is something
that must be continued in that storyline
there is something that must be must be
seen in some way and for the sake of my
character and having a job I hope the
faith comes out on top quite frankly and
the whole power the whole system
crumbles before us and we replace the
red cape with a another Sept that would
be my that will be my greatest desire
but I can't possibly endorse that that's
why we I think I think you've pissed off
Cersei Lannister I think you're in
trouble just personally speaking and
speaking as a fan no with absolutely no
knowledge or input yeah I would be I
mean I but it is a based one of those
battle royale situations that you're
building up to you know and I mean when
you the great thing about having this
situation is that when you have got a
character with such history of
negligence and suffering and Cersei
Lannister and you have this new
character of Jonathan in the but in the
flesh of Jonathan prices the high
Sparrow I mean Jonathan Pryce has bought
stuff into the character which is so
perfect and for me was actually really
quite inspiring to see which is the
ability to be totally reasonable totally
and utterly reasonable and make total
sense and be completely convincing in
his political and social documents which
is you don't seem to quite as he as he
says with the Queen of thorns
you don't seem to quite understand you
you're not quite able to really
understand the simplicity of what of
what's happening I serve the gods and
the gods demand justice and it is
imperfectly apt and an appropriate line
for the simplistic nature of their
ideology but he will never ever give you
reason to suspect that he's actually
orchestrating militant movements so it's
it's a great battle royale when it comes
to the new series and beyond we kind of
with the books second-guess where the
characters are gonna be does that mean
that everyone's walking around and
eggshells now sucking up to producers I
don't know because I'm not there you
don't know but I would suspect that most
actors that we just kind of like putting
a brave front on it and and day what
they do and nobody be sucking up for
fear that it looks like that yeah I
think they'll just be getting over there
saying and suddenly sorry yeah I I do I
do
leave that you know George the genius
mr. Martin who created this incredible
world
I do believe him and David and Dan would
speak in a regular basis I'm certain of
that they couldn't not so I mean for
example I get the feeling that one book
six and this is what for me is so
exciting this is the first season season
six the one they're making at the moment
this is the first season where there is
no guide whatsoever even when season
five come out a Dance with Dragons was
out and you know the storylines were
known and this is the first season where
everybody is completely in the dark
as I said I'm sure David and Dan and
George know them perfectly well but I
for one as a fan of the show I'm extra
ordinarily excited because I have no
idea I like that I don't actually like
spoilers I don't want the surprise to be
spoiled I don't want my Christmas
presents on Christmas Eve you know I
really I'm really excited for look I'm
really looking forward to season six
completely in the dark and anything can
happen I think he's absolutely right I
think one of the great one of the lucky
things about about the fact that we've
now gone into uncharted territory is the
fact that there is actually something
worse than having an unpleasant surprise
such as your character dying before
before you and that surprise is
believing very firmly based on the books
that you were good for the next season
and then actually finding out that they
changed the storyline and that you're
done that's not a nice way to discover
that to discover your situation we've
now gone into territory where the
storyline is liberated of expectation in
terms of the actors that are involved
and it means basically that the
storyline is in the hands of people who
are trying to to make it loyal to the
show make it a little to the books but
also maximize its enjoyment and maximize
their own interpretation of what will
make it better so that means that for us
actors we've I think that it gives you a
sense of kind of just sally forth sally
forth and whatever happens happens
no one is Jack Dan and David will
certainly talk with George but there's
no there's no precursor that is sort of
moved that it there
puppeteering what we're gonna do in the
show anymore it's it's in our tits in
our hands and that's that's a nice
feeling to have that's a very nice
feeling to have yeah well I mean what is
interesting is that if the rumor is true
and I think it is ideally Series six and
book six will come out at the same time
more or less sometime in spring book six
is apparently going to be published and
it will be fascinating because it's
completely open question will book six
actually try and square the circle and
show hive whatever deviation there's
being this is how these storylines are
coming together or have they actually
agreed listen your agenda is different
from mine
you follow your journey I'll follow mine
and we actually get to separate you know
resolutions of this journey so far and
it's quite legitimate and quite possible
that will be the second because the
demands of book right here completely
different for the demands of television
and I think some of the things that have
happened
TV wise have been because the boys have
not created for themselves an
expectation that they must have shock
value in each and every episode so
somehow no they've got to do that the
book doesn't have those pressures on it
in the same way and it may well be that
as I said they'll just do different
journeys and in some ways that'll be
fascinating you know just oh so you've
done this and we've done that and I
think we would even take pleasure in
there you know we would see our
characters going a direction that we
didn't go in the show and therefore you
are suddenly kind of you know somehow
you're you're still kind of going in
there in it in a way I felt that way
with Lancel when I got the story I
suddenly thought the Lancel that been
put before me is not the books Lancel
who has long gray falling out hair is
thin as a stick and is essentially sort
of you know literally was got one foot
in the coffin as he's mentioned in the
books he's not that they didn't write
him like that in this show he was not he
had to come back and he had to be it had
to be lost
straightaway loss there wasn't a
devolution there was he's gone most
people think he's dead this other entity
this ghost of Christmas past and he
comes back I can't actually remember or
think of a television show
that has been in this situation hmm
where you have this incredible set of
books written by this genius and you
have this incredible television series
by these geniuses and there's this
excitement over will the book come out
before the TV you know I can't remember
a TV show like that and that is the
magic of this program that is the
program but the boys have created these
boys and girls excuse me have created
and it has been such a privilege to be a
part of it I think Game of Thrones is a
game changer for television I really do
I think we're entering a golden age of
television
with all the new streaming platforms the
way technology is going the way social
medias going and I have never been so
excited to be an actor in television
than I am right now I think we're
entering a golden age and I think Game
of Thrones has set a seriously high
benchmark you've answered this question
before very well you go first well I
mean all those goes if I were other than
Who I am oh yeah it's a serpent or a
dragon I'd take both from the books and
and from the series you know it's great
character and I just always been
intrigued by that character and sort of
like followed it you know but you know
being Who I am I did actually read for
Tywin but I wouldn't want to compete
against chars and I did read for Mormons
from you know thought I was very happy
being Barristan
I don't know who else I might like to be
nuts that's enough to be getting older I
was just saying for me
the audition process for season one you
know he gets him for maybe one maybe two
maybe three year olds in the initial
castings I read for Jori Kasser Ned
Stark's right-hand man who Nikolaj very
kindly finished off very quickly
I like America so I wasn't done for half
of one season that was enough for five
seasons
Jamie sieves who played Jory Cassell was
perfect as Jory Kazan
he was absolutely perfect he nailed it
and he did a much better job than I
would have done if I'd been casting and
the casting in my opinion and just
speaking as a fan of the show it's so
good that wouldn't you see somebody in a
little you couldn't think of anybody
else doing it you couldn't think of
anybody else playing that role so I'll I
was very happy with sir Marin and I
wouldn't have wanted to be anybody else
because they would have done it better I
I auditioned for Joffrey I wouldn't want
to play I was so happy I was so no not
because of the nature of his character
would've been fun to do but I would not
be as as satisfied as I am had I not
played Lancel because it was a very
important it was a very important story
for me to be able to go from a young and
rather um rather innocent and you know
in some ways fairly fairly shortly
exposed Lannister to a member of the of
the faith militant and that mature that
maturity let's not forget is also really
part of why the character Landstuhl is
who he is it's not just a religion he's
older he's literally old it was his
small things I weighed about 40 pounds
more than I did
playing Lancel the sparrow then I did
playing Lance or the squire or Lance or
the night he's bigger and he's he's he's
taller he's older it's it's white why
most of the people who were downstairs
when they when they steals or photos of
me is Lance and in season two with
Goldilocks and lancelin season five they
go was it the same person they actually
thought you were they what they they
they they and most people thought and
most people thought I was recast and I
mean it's said in that I mean by the way
I took great pleasure in that I was I
was I because I was able to I was I was
allowed to tweet and put out on a social
media the fact that Lance I was coming
back I was allowed to but I didn't until
well basically I was at the premiere and
it was common knowledge because I did
not want to I wanted the the the walk up
to Thursday to be as
confusing and revelatory as it was so
yeah I definitely would've wanted to
play Lancer the whole time I'm very
lucky in that sense
you